mais de quoi va-t-on se paraît
aujourd'hui on se parle de ceux causés
dans cette petite boîte des trouvailles
en laisse signé lg ce sont les ailes
jetten free les fn s'ils sont des
écouteurs intra auriculaires que vous
avez dans cette petite boîte là je vous
en parlais je trouve d'expliquer à
commencer par la grosse promesse qui est
fait par alger là dessus à savoir que
cette boîte ce boîtier va supprimer 99
99% des bactéries ça c'est plutôt
intéressant c'est assez différent et
surtout dans une période un peu
compliquée comme aujourd'hui
eh bien on aime bien avoir des produits
qui sont intelligents qui les toits qui
donne un petit côté aussi rassurant
alors ici on parle bien de bactéries on
va parler déchiré chaque colis on va
parler de staphylocoques dorés on ne
parle pas de dieu me suis donc ça il
faut aussi savoir j'ai tout de suite
vous détailler ce côté là parce que si
on veut que ça marche il faut qu'il soit
branché sur le secteur est ici et
uniquement sur secteur pendant 10
minutes
mais vous pouvez également venir les
recharger ici son fils si vous voulez
recharger son fils ça ne marchera pas si
vous les mettez dans leur boîtier sans
les recharger ça ne marchera pas ça
marchera uniquement avec de la charge
sur le secteur pendant 10 minutes voilà
ça il faut le savoir et autres petits
points de détails lorsque vous les
ouvrez vous avez petite lumière bleue
qui l'avenir à l'intérieur ici la
lumière vous voyez sont juste des
petites led pour faire beau pour venir
illustrer le propos puisque la lumière
ultraviolette
vous ne voyez pas c'est une lumière qui
est invisible à l'oeil nu alors
maintenant on va se parler de ces petits
empruntera trueye en laisse - première
chose que j'ai vu quand je les ai
découvert que j'étais ouvert que ses
amis et mes oreilles
ce que je trouve vraiment super sympa
c'est le confort se positionne très
facilement il rentre vraiment dans votre
conduit auditif très facilement et rien
que pour ça c'est un gros pouce bleus
pour lg le confort et la en plus ici
vous avez la réduction de bruit passive
c'est-à-dire qu'ils vont venir obstrué
votre canal auditif de la même manière
que si vous prenez vos doigts vous les
mettez dedans hop au bouche à oreille ça
vous bougez exactement de la même
manière les rails alors ici réduction
brute passive à ne pas confondre avec la
réduction bruit active
on est uniquement sur un système
mécanique qui vient vous boucher les
oreilles mais ça bouge plutôt bien ça
marche plutôt bien vous avez un bon
confort en plus de l'intérieur de votre
boîte trois tailles d'embouts en
silicone pour venir pourrait les en
boucle correspondant à votre morphologie
puisque oui on n'a pas tous la même
morphologie et puisque ici ce qui nous
intéresse le plus c'est l'audio on va en
parler il faut savoir qu'ici vous avez
un haut parleur par écouteurs en haut
parleurs 2
si mm un petit transducteurs vous en
avez pas deux vous en avez un seul ce
qui est intéressant dans le feu dans la
barre de c'est qu'on pourra venir
séparer le signal les aigus d'un côté
les graphes de l'autre pour venir
optimiser la qualité sonore ici autant
d'années un seul bon c'est un peu
standard il faut vraiment venir après
resituer ce produit par rapport à son
positionnement tarifaire vous êtes à 199
vous le trouvez d'ailleurs moins cher
chez boulanger heurte une vidéo qui a
réalisé aujourd'hui en partenariat avec
des ondées ils ont mis un petit lien en
bas d'un escrimeur pour venir découvrir
ce produit surtout pour le trouve un
tarif extrêmement intéressant une fois
de plus je vous renvoie aux liens qui
est en bas dans la description parce que
j'aime bien sûr ces produits c'est qu'on
va avoir une qualité qui est correct on
va pas avoir des basses surboosté on va
pas voir les aigus les plus brillants à
noter si vous avez uniquement le codec
ac et sd c'est pas 2 ap et explique ce
jeudi et compagnie n'ont ici a assez sb
c'est son nom des écouteurs trouvailles
en laisse qui fonctionne avec du
bluetooth 5.0 vous avez en tout quatre
petits micros de par écouteurs le micro
qui va situé sur le haut de vos
écouteurs va venir pour réduire les co
risque celui qui est situé en bas avec
là pour apporter plus de clarté avant de
voir et ça fonctionne très bien pour nos
appels téléphoniques avant moi ce que je
vous conseille de ça pour vous appel
téléphonique
c'est d'activer le son ambiant pour
venir entendre votre voix sinon vous
avez l'impression de parts avec les
doigts dans les oreilles les oreilles
bouchées c'est pas extrêmement confort
vous activez le son bien vous avez un
petit pavé tactile vous laissez votre
doigt appuyé ça vous active l'ambiante
mode le son ambiant c'est plutôt
agréable pour quelques couches et
normand vous avez un côté un petit peu
pas et comme et vous avez un peu de
réverbération de par le son qui est
captée l'extérieur qui vous est
restituée dans vos écouteurs c'est bien
pour de lapointe je suis pas sûr de
faire des grandes conversations de
quelques heures avec mais pour un peu
d'appoint de temps en temps lorsque vous
posez sur les rails quelqu'un vous
appelle
bon ça marche plutôt bien ils sont bien
évidemment compatible avec vos
assistants locaux que sont syrie et
google assistants et vous avez une
certification ipx4 résistant à l'eau et
à la poussière alors ici on va pas aller
se baigner avec on va parler à la
piscine est par contre si vous êtes dans
la rue qui se met à pleuvoir et bien
vous êtes tranquille et si vous
transpirez en faisant du sport vous êtes
tranquille d'ailleurs justement le sport
parlons-en
comme vous avez une très bonne tenue
dans votre oreille et bien vous pouvez
aller courir faire du running avec de la
marche rapide de la marche nordique vous
pourrez faire plein d'activités en
extérieur ils sont vraiment bien une
fois de plus on ne va pas dans la
piscine avec on est vite sinon les abus
et compris l'histoire comme je le disais
si on a de la commande tactile
on se rapproche pour tout le monde ça
comment tactile et je trouve plutôt bien
et surtout elle est personnalisable
depuis l'application mais ça je le
montre dans quelques instants
regardez hop là j'entends connectées
disques d'être directement j'appuie une
fois plein et puis une fois pause
quelqu'un m'appelle je puis une fois je
décroche
si je suis en conversation j'ai appuyé
deux fois je raccroche et si j'écoute de
la musique et que j'appuie deux fois ça
va me monte le son sur l'écouteur droit
ça puis deux fois sur l'écouteur gauche
je les ai pas je sais c'est un peu
factice s'appuie deux fois ça va baisser
le son et si j'appuie trois fois tac tac
tac morceau suivant et l'appui long je
vous l'expliquais c'est pour activer le
son ambiant votre application se situe
juste ici c'est l'application lg tonnes
free ici vous allez pouvoir gérer vos
écouteurs très facilement première chose
vous voyez s'il se recruter ou pas c'est
quand même la base ils le sont le niveau
de batterie vous êtes d'accès ensuite un
équaliseur équaliseur complètement
personnalisable moi j'ai personnalisés
j'en ai créé un ici vous avez choix
entre quatre modes différents immersif
basbous naturel triebel boost ce que je
vous conseille de faire vraiment c'est
vraiment premier temps de le faire c'est
de créer votre propre équaliseur je suis
venu remonter un petit peu les basses je
lui casse et entre 250 et 500 fut dur
ajouté un petit peu de clarté un peu de
précision au niveau de fréquence rené le
temps d'écouter essayer tester voyez ce
qui marche ou pas vous avez soit entre 2
équaliseur custom un custom de c'est
très très bien et après peut choisir un
autre si vous souhaitez immersif mars
quand même plutôt pas mal
vous avez basbous le naturel tribal bull
à vous de voir vraiment ce que vous
préférez utiliser ensuite vous retrouver
ici à des paramètres de notification ça
c'est assez rigolo ça va venir lire vos
sms naissent réseaux sociaux jeux les
muons nettement vous avez une voix
masculine qui vous lit vos messages et
ça va assez vite a pas forcément
ponctuation on a un peu de mal à
comprendre mais bon pourquoi pas c'est
assez rigolo pourrait bien modifier
ensuite le débit de la parole rapide
normale dans à vous de voir ce qui peut
potentiellement vous intéresser et
ensuite vous venez paramétrer ici le
pavé tactile et ça je trouve ça vraiment
super intéressant déjà assez didactique
qui nous explique comment ça marche
depuis une fois gauche arrêt lecture
droite à la lecture mais je peux me dire
par exemple qui a publié une fois à
gauche je pas que ce soir et lectures
pense que m une commande vocale à gauche
et play pause à droite ça ça vraiment un
sens pourquoi pas ensuite toucher deux
fois augmenter le volume diminuer le
volume ça pour moi c'est extrêmement
pertinents et puis touché trois fois
morceaux suivants morceaux suivants dont
ça s'est un petit peu stupide morceau
suivant à droite tu d'accord mais à
gauche morceau précédent
et là par contre on a une super
configuration et là ça devient
très très intuitif alors il vous le
marque par contre vous ne pouvez pas
modifié la réception d'un appel avec un
appui vous pouvez pas modifier non plus
la fin d'un appel avec deux appuis que
vous pouvez pas modifié l' appui long
avec bruit ambiant mais au-delà de ça
déjà ce que pouvait faire là c'est
vraiment très pratique ça vous permet de
l'utiliser de façon très maligne en
utilisant toutes les fonctions
directement depuis votre pavé tactile
une fonction qui est assez rigolote
s'est trouvé les écouteurs quand vous
les avez perdu vous appuyez ici ça va
émettre un son à sa solde
où est il en fait il est là donc voila
moi ça je le sais ces pratiques je peux
arrêter
vous pouvez ensuite faire les mises à
jour logicielles si vous souhaitez puis
vous avez un petit guide d'utilisateur
qui vous explique comment sa marquise
ont des fonctions basiques qui ne
prennent pas en compte la
personnalisation vous venez de faire des
par contre ça vous explique comment ça
marche pour venir le recharger sans fil
vous pouvez activer ou désactiver le son
ambiant monter le volume verrouiller le
pavé tactile est enfin vous voyez ça
c'est très pratique quand j'ai un seul
petit reproche à dire fournir ici sur la
commande tactile c'est que lorsque vous
avez vos écouteurs dans vos oreilles et
que vous voulez tapoter dessus on
l'entend vous avez ce bruit qui se
répercute dans votre oreille c'est pas
hyper agréable vous allez le faire vous
allez le faire un peu doucement on sent
la vibration l'écouteur bon voilà ça
c'est un petit peu le point de reproches
et vous allez retrouver juste ici un
petit indicateur de lumière vous le
voyez quand il est bleu c'est que vous
avez plus de 80 % de charge quand qui
les violait vous avez entre 20 et 80 %
de charge et lorsqu'il est rouge vous
avez moins de 20 % de charge les faut
venir le recharger et puisqu'on parle de
recharge au part de l'autonomie vous
avez en tout maximum jusqu'à 18 heures
d'écouté vous avez six heures au niveau
des écouteurs plus deux fois six heures
supplémentaires grâce à votre petit
boîtier de recharge pour monter jusqu'à
18h vous ai compris les écouteurs six
heures avec le boîtier jusqu'à 18 heures
si vous arrivez vraiment a plus grand
chose au niveau de la batterie vous leur
charge et cinq minutes et d'être parti
pour une heure d'écouté et puis vous
avez en plus de suspense une fois de
plus un très grand classique du
détecteur de présence lorsque vous
mettez dans votre oreille il va
reconnaître effectivement qu'il est
positionné il va se connecter il va
sapere directement à votre smartphone
quel qu'il soit que vous ayez
smartphones ios ou un smartphone android
mois ces petits écouteurs
je trouve plutôt bien ce que j'aime bien
c'est effectivement le fait qu'ils vont
venir se nettoyer et qu'ils vont dire
supprimer des bactéries grâce aux
ultraviolets schultz quelque chose qui
est intéressant et c'est bien qu'elle
gèle intégrer si ça je l'avais déjà vu
et d'un lien je pense que c'était
janvier 2001 lorsque j'étais parti au
csa vegas il avait montré à techno j'ai
trouvé extrêmement intéressante et très
pertinente et la partie audio est bien
on est un peu limité parce qu'on a un
seul transducteurs on aurait eu deux on
aurait pu aller un peu plus loin pour
venir élargir ce signal mais comme ça
fait très bien le tas et s'il ya deux
points que j'aime beaucoup le premier
s'avère effectivement le confort sont
vraiment très confortable trouve très
facilement leur position dans vos
oreilles et puis le deuxième c'est
l'application qui vous permet de dire
personnaliser les équaliseur et surtout
de pouvoir dire personnaliser vos
commandes tactiles a vous de me dire
vous maintenant ce que vous en pensez en
bas en commentaire comment vous les
trouvez ces petits lg tonnes free fr
6 est ce que voulait trouver intéressant
oui donc pas comment marquer ma tout ça
en bas en commentaire est une fois de
plus je vous renvoie aux liens pour
venir les découvrir
on se retrouve très bientôt cotonou pour
moitié doit parler évidemment de teck
parler d'écouteurs il se peut qu'on
parle encore ne yo de six très très très
très peu de temps donc vous invite à
venir me rejoindre
c'est pas déjà le cas sur ce je vous
embrasse beaucoup d'amour pour la soirée
vous du lauréat bientôt ciao